[Música]
y vamos directo a la zona fronteriza
entre españa y marruecos porque hoy se
reabre esta zona limítrofe de ceuta y
melilla esto tras dos años cerrada por
la pandemia y luego de una crisis
diplomática entre ambos países nuestra
corresponsal sofía catalana está en
castillejos sofía qué gusto saludarla
nuevamente vamos a hablar entonces de la
reapertura le pregunto cuáles son las
claves para entender la importancia de
esta decisión sofía
hola raul muchas gracias pues como
comentabas en las fronteras de ceuta y
melilla se han reabierto ahora después
de más de dos años cerradas un cierre
que se decretó debido a la pandemia pero
que se prolongó como bien explicaba se
debido a la crisis diplomática que
mantuvieron españa y marruecos una
crisis vea que cabe destacar pues se
saldó con el reconocimiento público por
parte del gobierno español hacia su
apoyo al plan de autonomía marroquí para
el sáhara occidental' y dicho esto raúl
efectivamente nos encontramos aquí muy
cerca de ceuta justo en la otra parte de
la frontera en la parte a marroquí en la
ciudad de castillejos y lo que hemos
podido ver aquí al final ha sido una
reapertura muy parcial prácticamente es
simbólica de el enclave español y por
qué pues porque de momento solamente van
a poder acceder las personas que tengan
a pasaporte europeo o un visado schengen
en cambio los trabajadores marroquíes
tiran fronteras van a tener que esperar
hasta el día 31 de mayo para que ustedes
se ubiquen aquí en la frontera de ceuta
justo antes del cierre los ciudadanos
marroquíes el que tienen la residencia
en la provincia limítrofe de tetuán pues
podían acceder al enclave español sin
visado solamente con su documento
nacional de identidad marroquí eso sí
pues no se podían desplazar a españa
península ni tampoco pernoctar dentro de
la enclave español y qué es lo que
ocurre pues que muchos de estos
ciudadanos marroquíes tienen contrato de
trabajo en ceuta por eso se les llama
que a transfronterizos se calcula que
son alrededor de cinco mil personas y
que ocurrió pues que con el cierre de
las fronteras estas personas que o sea
la mayoría les caducaron los permisos de
trabajo y ahora el ministerio del
interior de expaña les exige un visado
para poder volver a entrar a los
enclaves y hablábamos con estas personas
raúl nos comentaban pues que viven una
situación límite hace dos años que no
tienen ingresos y ni tampoco reciben
prestaciones sociales y eso a pesar de
haber cotizado durante años
seguridad social española y por otra
parte también cabe destacar que tanto
autoridades marroquíes como españolas
han reforzado los controles policiales a
ambos lados de la frontera y también han
anunciado la prohibición total sobre
contrabando claro sofía pero por qué son
tan importantes estas fronteras para
marruecos para españa y también para la
unión europea además tenemos entendido
que precisamente el paso está ahora
lleno de militares no
exactamente sí raúl pues es que ceuta y
melilla al final son las únicas
fronteras terrestres de la unión europea
aquí en áfrica y además están entre las
más desiguales del mundo también las
fronteras de ceuta y melilla son clave
para entender las relaciones entre
españa marruecos y la unión europea mira
por una parte tenemos el tema del
control migratorio y es que desde hace
décadas a marruecos se recibe cantidades
millonarias de dinero anualmente para
controlar esta frontera euro africana
que es lo que hace marruecos pues se
impide el paso de migrantes e sin visado
al enclave español y también ejecuta
desplazamientos a forzado o sea pues muy
lejos de la frontera y por otra parte es
muy importante pues es saber que a
marruecos ella reivindica su soberanía
sobre ceuta y en melilla y utiliza este
discurso a la par que el tema del
control migratorio pues para presionar a
españa ya la unión europea de cara a
alcanzar algunas de sus metas
diplomáticas más importantes como es el
caso por ejemplo del occidental y
precisamente raúl que se cumple esta
semana un año de la que fue la mayor
crisis migratoria vivida jamás en la
frontera de ceuta que fue lo que pasó
pues que en plena crisis
diplomática con españa más hueco se
levantó el control migratorio y
alrededor de 10.000 personas lograron
acceder sin visado al enclave español
personas que después por cierto fueron
expulsadas por el ejército español de
nuevo marc huecos a sin seguir ningún
tipo de procedimiento legal y tras la
helada la reconciliación diplomática
entre los países pues marruecos ha
rebajado ahora la intensidad digamos de
sus reclamos o sobre ceuta y melilla y
también ha acordado con españa y aparte
de la reapertura de las fronteras a pues
el refuerzo del control migratorio